yo what's up we're gonna be doing a
bunch of like how to bait tricks videos
pretty period I was bringing food I was
seeing Liam playing a fortnight with a
fan today where is he from Palestine
Palestine this looks you can do it you
did see you guys on the next one stay
lifted stay happy stay bait stave eight
let me guess you're pretending to be a
dragon with shitty parents those serial
rapists are Natan Liam Liam is the cute
one and neither of them is the smart one
and no they don't have speech
impediments they're just Canadians
millions of subscribers watch the Nate
420 and Liam vapes YouTube channel to
see them pushing fat clouds while
waiting on complex geopolitical issues
naveen is for the classlist who want to
use their glorified iPod shuffles a
personal fog machine like their David
Copperfield
my favorite Dave trick is when the
batteries explode in their faces
hot mango blue melon berry rush without
vape pens kids wouldn't know what fruit
tastes like is there a link between
vaping and seizures god I hope so
but Natan Liam just want to have an
intelligent discussion about squawking
thick NIC rips from rebuildable with sub
ohm coils sick goose necks and pointy
grub screws that toot massive vapor with
kick from the mg strength that's why I
flew them through actual clouds to LA an
entire city hot-boxed and smog for this
week's ce-web-rity profile
[Applause]
natan Liam my favorite Canadian cloud
pusses get in here how's it going depend
we're doing good I lost one of the hot
box and all Beatrice but I'm not much of
a vapor or smoker
I prefer dip just doesn't have the
negative stigma how'd you guys meet we
were working together at McDonald's
actually house we're gonna MacDonald's
farm awful is it especially in Canada
yes why is it worse in Canada I couldn't
tell you
you like Canada I would say top three or
four countries in North America how many
countries are in North America three
that's what I've read things but the
reality is all of Central America is
North America Nicaragua Costa Rica no
not in Brazil dude no geography bro
forward vaping nowhere bateman we're
baking I apologize were you surprised at
all that your videos got so popular very
how did they even get the time I'll be
like in the car I'll bake dude let's I'm
bored let's just go film a video the
nice thing about doing it in a car this
cars actually can move around when the
dough mage hits you out of 10
what's the dome each level dude most
people already know but this is the mid
gangbang what's with the shirtless
episodes so you gotta keep them spicy
you know okay so you guys were getting
sexy The Naked Bike the pop-up box we
were nothing under there - it was naked
babe you just didn't know I did not know
that what about that Palestine video a
fan from where is he from Palestine
Palestine and I could hear gunshots
right
I'm gonna take a double hit did anybody
you on how to say Palestine yeah I don't
really read my comments to be honest
there's like this one fan and he was
like telling us about his situation he'd
like be walking to school and you get
like teargas every morning and chill
every morning in tears I stopped going
to school talked about some of the
tricks that you guys are doing how do
you do babe tricks how'd you guys learn
them practice yeah just might looking
like an idiot most of the time what's
your favorite vape trick the ghost okay
show me the ghost
it's wrong mine's bad
oh my haribol I liked it though he's
Oh French in there you were smoking with
your mom right yep in Easter so happy
Easter to everybody how are things work
with her whenever she's around me you
know you sound like when you talk like
that you ever see those guys that were
hiding their identity
who's going say if you want to see your
kid alive again leave a half a million
dollars in a briefcase it's you who
wanted your kid alive again man what is
with the meat oh I figured I'd use all
your smoke to infuse a little flavor
into my brisket as a vegan brisket but
she's nice party needs about six to
eight more hours Liam what was going on
your face and one episode he didn't say
anything about it but look look I got
the kicked out of Mirsad oh no
lesions or something the night before I
got a little bit too saucy with the boys
I fell down a hell it's just
like mad baby people don't notice about
us and you think it's a rigged word baby
no that was not funny it was dead ass I
mean Lee got ringworm from it and just
kept drinking like nothing happened okay
you guys are really into hydration we
got some water just a safe hydrated of
course we have under 100 milliliters of
water for the sick sent that humans have
had from the beginning of time you know
find water what's your beef against pop
pop just doesn't hydrate you bro okay
but I'm like two percent water and 100
percent sugar well that'd be 102 percent
may 4 24 2000 in what we call puking and
Charlie chundan I didn't know that you
have a few too many brews with the boys
he's got a muck a chunky and then you go
right back to partying like nothing
happened what do you normally make this
is a smoke nerd right here uh-huh
let's get a little vapor cocky going oh
no big tricks are you guys getting
sponsored I got voo poo actually this
company oh nice boo-boo shout out poopoo
why was your YouTube channel shut down
your ask YouTube like I can't and we
don't even know they put they have a
broken system right because I see videos
too like of women bent over all fours
delivering their baby in their house
like shits coming out their asshole
it's just the most disgusting thing in
the world but it since its pregnancy
it's like beautiful they don't do
anything about it but you have two kids
in a car vaping and that's that's
offensive to all right got you guys a
little something for coming all this way
that custom mod of this bad boy let's
see those pussies over a jewel compete
with this monster the battery's big
enough oh yeah
well I'm feeling a little lightheaded
I'm not gonna lie to you me too man
don't you think hot boxing or running a
pickup truck in the garage might be a
little dangerous what do we learn to
their kids
people who vape are stupid and the
sooner they pass on the better off we
all are
[Music]
[Applause]
you